I'm Vernor Vinge II and I'm a science
fiction writer I really felt a sort of
internal intellectual revolution when I
read David Friedman's machinery of
freedom
the sort of pure form that David
Friedman wrote about machinery of
freedom and wrote about it very very
attractively and brilliantly made a big
difference to me
science fiction has always been the
great reading influence on me starting
with writers like Paul Anderson and
Robert Heinlein laughter see Clark and
many more but those are three very
important ones science fiction more than
any other genre that I know about allows
you to write stories that experiment
with things and fiction in general more
than any other art form is one that uses
the consumers mind and imagination as a
display device and so this means that in
theory a writer if they can engage the
reader can impress readers that are a
lot smarter than the writer is rainbows
end grew out of a story with a similar
technology called fast times at
Fairmount high and I tried to make the
world a lot you know quite recognizable
from our present world but it just takes
the trends that I think everybody you
know who's who's watching this online is
very much aware of and just pushes those
with a couple elements that are just
beginning to become widely you know
popular one is the notion of embedded
processors in almost everything the
other is that those are networked and
the the the third thing is that these
devices
know where they are and they can talk to
one another that is sort of an internet
beneath the internet a digital plankton
layer and that's that can support some
very strange things especially once you
get proper display devices the way I use
the term singularity is to what I'm
talking about technology is the the
feeling that in the relatively near
historical future that we humans using
technology will create or become
creatures of superhuman intelligence and
the reason why this is special compared
to other forms of technological progress
is that if it happens then the
fundamental thing that has put us at the
top of the what we regard is the top of
the pyramid in the world it has now been
trumped and that there is is something
in that direction something even better
than is that is going along and so in
the in the 1800's in the 1900s and in
the 20th century you could talk about
and predict a technology some people
were right and some people were wrong
and in the end things that what's
happened is probably mostly unexpected
but if you could magically talk to
somebody from the 1800's like Mark Twain
who would be all ears since he was a
technophile you could explain what's
going in on in in our era probably in as
much time as this interview is taking
and he might not believe you but he
would understand what you were saying
that's what it's like to talk about
technological progress before the
singularity to talk about technological
progress after the singularity and
explain that
for that the explanation exercise would
be like trying to imagine how we could
explain our present era to a goldfish or
a flatworm it's intrinsically
inaccessible in a very simplified way we
have makers and breakers in the world
and we and the smart people in the world
have made so many wonderful things and
it's so easy for the breakers to use
them and breakers have all sorts of
motives including just the motive of
breaking it because it's so beautiful
and people are so happy with it I think
actually in the last five years there's
been last ten years there's been two
things that have have made me tilt more
to think that that that the makers can
can keep the breakers from bringing
everything down and the first of those
is the is the penetration of cell phones
between worldwide between 2000 and 2010
and that is something that it exceeds if
you would put that in a science fiction
story you would have gotten flack for a
thing oh that's typical 1940 ish
over-the-top impossible you know don't
you know how I was you know social
things can't change like that especially
it constructive things and that one
thing is just so awesome and its impact
is so awesome that that's a very big
plus it makes me sort of tend toward the
makers and the other is is something
whose story is not finished and you know
we can all still be made to look very
foolish if we say it but I think a small
small things like Wikipedia which is not
a small thing but I mean small thing
compared to the end of the world or the
or the salvation of the world but
Wikipedia if you would ask me in 1995
again well what about this idea that's
it now don't you know that there are
people who like to just defile and when
it's as easy as it is with with the web
did to file things there are breakers
out there they would never let
it's work and the fact that it has
worked so magnificently is in a way it
even gives me some hope for the you know
really serious violent breakage that
that technology will eventually make
possible